[Music]
and Chris and I'm a product manager here
on our cloud data proc team and I'm
really excited for this presentation
because we need to talk about all the
cool features that we've come up with
since our last cloud next and I even get
to do it with two of our Rockstar
engineers I got with me Mikaela as well
as Karthik and they've actually built a
lot of the features we're about to show
you the way I want to start is just by
making sure that everyone knows
everything that you're about to see is
publicly available go out kick the tires
on it we'd love to hear feedback you can
go use everything we're about to go to
talk about now I have a ton of things I
want to get to so I'm gonna just start
to jump in and quickly though before I
do the new features I want to quickly
baseline on what Cloud Data proc is so
Cloud Data proc this is Google cloud
platforms fully managed Apache spark and
Hitachi Hadoop service and I'm saying
Hadoop and spark but it's really an
engine for running lots of open source
software in that ecosystem we give you
customizable machine types meaning that
you can have a set of machine learning
jobs running on one cluster that might
be very compute intensive well at the
same time you have some ad hoc bi
applications that are running on a
memory intensive cluster and the to
never have to contend for resources but
can still be reading and writing from
the same cloud storage datasets and we
also had some customers that create very
large customers with us oh you know when
they need clusters like this so and they
can just take them down when they're
done so for instance you know our
engineers we're working with Twitter and
they received a note that it's like hey
you know are we your largest data proc
classic cluster and we kind of look at
each other we're like I don't know what
are you talking about we didn't check
and they had actually just needed a
90,000 core cluster and were able to go
create that on-demand
never getting a hold of the data protein
we're in about confer cure meant just
went created a 90,000 core data proc
cluster and then tore it down when they
were
with it and so they're able to do this
because we have a lot of tools and
features that are specifically designed
for supporting these kind of
architectures and ephemeral Hadoop and
spark clusters in general and we give
you a lot of tight integration back to
the rest of Google cloud so we are not
just giving you yet
another cluster that you're gonna have
to go manage we are letting you run all
of your existing open source software
but still modernizing your stack as you
as we do this and we give our Cloud Data
product customers a lot of flexibility
and how they choose to run the data proc
service so we expose a lot of knobs now
we try to put same defaults on those
knobs if you don't want to deal with
that you can just go and get started
very easily but those knobs are exposed
and so we have customers that use data
product in a couple different models the
first model is this idea of a Java
scoped cluster and this is really
effective for our cloud data prop
customers with batch or ETL type jobs
now in this mode you can have a single
command that will send a graph of jobs
to cloud data proc we will spit up a
right sized cluster run those jobs make
sure that cluster gets torn down and
then save all of that information about
what happened all the out logging and
audits in the stack driver for you and
this works really well with cloud data
proc because we can usually give you a
fully loaded Hadoop and spark cluster in
around 90 seconds so when you only have
a minute and a half overhead to creating
a cluster you can start to think about
jobs and clusters almost as this single
entity and we have a lot of features
that are going to help you with this
model things like our jobs API workflow
templates and clustered scheduled
deletion but we also have customers that
tell us they have scenarios for long
running Cloud Data proc clusters and
these might be scenarios for things like
you know if there's a shared interactive
analysis with Jupiter or Zeppelin
notebooks
or maybe they're building bi
applications based on Druid and we have
plenty of features like our high
availability mode and our autoscaler
that are going to help with this model
too and if you want to learn more
Michaela and I actually did a top 10
tips'
article on the Google data analytics
blog a couple months back you can find
and she even has a webinar associated
with that so there's a lot of materials
out there if you want to know more about
how to run long standing cloud data proc
clusters but regardless of the model
that you choose our goal with cloud data
proc is changing open source software to
be cloud native this means making
features that are going to be fast easy
and cost effective last year alone we
put more than 30 new features into cloud
data proc and so this is still an area
Google is heavily investing in and so
now let's jump in and actually start
talking about some of these new features
and what's going on in cloud data proc
so I'm gonna start by talking about some
of the recent open source software we've
recently integrated with cloud data
products now the theme to all these
features that I'm about to talk about is
the cloud data proc lets you take the
open source tools algorithms and
programming languages that you're
already using today but make it really
easy to apply them to cloud scale data
sets while at the same time helping you
integrate with the entire GCP ecosystem
we've just recently launched a new
version of cloud data pockets now
generally available version 1.4 the
headliner on this version is probably
sparked 2.4 and that comes with a lot of
usability and stability updates and
that's something that you can really
start to combine with cloud data proc we
also had a lot of customers that told us
hey we love cloud data proc but we've
built so much of our enterprise tooling
and internal standards around Ubuntu so
we went back and we recreated data proc
on Ubuntu and that exposed a
new knob a choice of image or operating
system type for data proc now for years
we've had customers that have built in
very tight and sophisticated security
controls with cloud iam and VM and
cluster isolation but we've also had
customers that wanted the open source
tools like Kerberos built directly into
data proc which is why we now have a
beta version of Kerberos integrated with
data proc and this is going to let you
do things like tie back your data proc
users to Active Directory or it makes it
a simple button click to turn on Hadoop
secure mode or add encryption in flight
tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. I'm gonna be
speaking with cloud era on securing your
data Lakes and essentially we're gonna
have this a 55 minute presentation on
this entire slide feel if you are
interested in what's going on in Hadoop
security I'd recommend that session
tomorrow morning but back to data praça
itself you know when we're you create a
data processor you can specialize by
what we call an initialization action
that's an executable or script the Cloud
Data proc is going to run on all nodes
of your cluster immediately after that
cluster spins up now we talk to a lot of
our customers and we ask them you know
we try to identify the most common open
source software that's being installed
on cloud data proc and then what we want
to do is we try to provide starter
scripts so everyone's not rewriting that
same code and those are the
initialization actions that we put into
our github repository some of the more
recent initialization actions include
Apache Ranger and we find a lot of
customers when they start with cloud
data proc they might be starting with a
you know a pretty monolithic on-prem
cluster that sharing resources between
ad hoc bi analysts who are trying to run
their sequel queries and waiting for
those queries to come back along with a
lot of scheduled and batch jobs that
have piled up over the last couple years
and so one of the first ways that
customers start to migrate to the cloud
is they take a lot of those batch and
skids with jobs and start putting them
into
data Prague to free up that on-prem
cluster for the analyst and we've had
customers that said hey the code it maps
over great everything runs but I would
really love to keep all of my existing
security controls and policies without
redeveloping all of that and so that's
where something like the Apache Ranger
initialization action can really help
get them started doing that we've also
recently created an initialization
action for HBase and while we do at
Google cloud have BigTable which is a no
sequel store with HBase api
compatibility customers they've told us
hey sometimes I just need Co processes
or I want to run Apache Phoenix with
sequel and so that's why we came out
with the Apache HBase we also have the
fish that you see there that stands for
tawny or tensorflow on yarn and that's a
project that we did with LinkedIn that
makes it easy to run tensorflow jobs on
your data proc cluster without having to
move over to a separate API like CM le
you can just call it directly from your
SPARC workflows and have tensorflow
scale and there's actually a full next
session tomorrow at 11:40 that you might
want to check out if you want to learn
more about that one but again the theme
here you're probably sitting here is
staring at all these open-source logos
and you might be thinking hey doesn't
Google have a fully managed offering for
some of this stuff and you're right
oftentimes they do but cloud data
product our goal is just to make it easy
to run that open-source version of the
software if that's your preference now
we've also recently had some optional
components that got promoted to either
GA or beta and an optional component
that's what happens when initialization
actions it reaches enough popularity
that we decide we're gonna make this a
first class data proc citizen an
optional component that's software that
you can just add with a simple checkbox
and that becomes part of the data proc
image and so that gives you the fast
clusters bit of time but it also gets
you fully integrated with all of data
proc and if you want to know what I mean
by fully integrated you know that's
something go talk to your cluster admin
about they probably know what it's like
to try to keep up with all the latest
versions of this various open source
software and keep everything in sync you
know you go you install the latest
version of spark it's you know a
butterfly flaps its wings it steps on
some Java dependency over in Zeppelin
and now of a sudden all your class pass
or misaligned like that's the kind of
things that because we bake you know the
optional components into the image
itself that ensures that this whole
menagerie of open-source software is
actually working in tandem and a new
optional component we just put into
alpha is druid a column-oriented open
source distributed data store you'll
most often find this with a lap
applications on really high volume data
so one common use case that I keep
seeing with GCP customers is they're
taking something like an Apache Kafka or
a confluent incoming stream they land
all of that data into a Google Cloud
storage sink and then you know folks
want to see dashboards on that data
about what's coming in in real time and
they might want that daily they might
want that hourly and so they can
schedule a cloud data proc cluster to
spin up run those aggregations up cert
that into a long-running cloud data proc
Lester running druid and then tear down
that cluster that was running that those
jobs and then you have your application
for the dash boarding or whatever going
against that OLAP cloud data proc store
running druid the data product jobs API
we have a new spark our job type
available for that now the data proc
jobs API that's what makes it possible
to submit a job to an existing cloud
data proc cluster with jobs dot submit
call over HTTP or if you're on a
command-line interface you can use
g-cloud or even in the Google cloud
platform console itself and so now it's
possible to submit your spark our jobs
through that jobs API which has them
logged and monitored and that makes it
really easy to build automated tooling
around your our code it also makes it
pretty easy to start separating the
permissions of who has access to the
cluster versus who has access just a job
against the cluster and you can do that
now without setting up gateway nodes or
something like Livy you can just use the
jobs API and a new feature that just
came out is this component gateway and
you see what it does here is I can now
which with one button click enable the
component gateway come into the web
interfaces and it will expose the web
UIs associated with the components that
are running on the cluster and I can
click into those based on my cloud iam
permissions and again this is a new
feature along the same lines of the jobs
API where we want to make it easy to
access data proc without a bunch of
sophisticated edge nodes or networking
set up we want to make it easy that you
can use you know GCP as your security
perimeter for some of the more common
scenarios so component gateway it was
built on top of Apache Knox and it
reverse proxies and exposes the web you
eyes and then as long as you have the
clapper the proper cloud iam permissions
you can directly access them so a lot of
clouds
they build when they build their
connectors they will keep them internal
so you have to be using their services
to take advantage of the first-class
connector and the open source community
they've done a great job of responding
to that and they started building their
own connectors but what we saw is that
created both a lot of friction in the
community as well as confusion from
customers about hey what connects your
connection should I really be using so
at Google we decided to take a different
approach all of the connectors that we
build from Hadoop into the Google cloud
platform those are fully open source so
we chose to work with the open source
community instead of against them and
our connectors they're also built with
these cross team collaborations at
Google
so our Google Cloud Storage connector
that is something that we did
hand-in-hand with the cloud storage team
to make sure that you're getting the
optimal performance out of these
connectors so to tell you more about
some of the new and improved connectors
that are available I'm gonna bring up
Karthik who is actually one of the
engineers on that
so data proc is really the bridge like I
we see it is the bridge between the
Hadoop world and Google cloud so it's
gotta be clear on what connectors means
the idea is that you can still store
your data and services like bigquery or
Google Cloud Storage that can be used
through other cloud platform tools but
at the same time process your data
through tools that you're already
familiar with in your kind of Hadoop
ecosystem so the first what I'm going to
go through a few new connectors and this
is like the first one I think this is
really the coolest it's a set of new
bigquery read connectors so the old
bigquery connectors the way it worked is
they would export data from bigquery
into GCS and then your job would read
the data from GCS what that meant is
that your cluster actually sat idle for
you know maybe up to minutes as that
data was being exported what through
this new bigquery storage API we can
actually stream data directly from
bigquery and bigquery actually
intelligently like dynamically
rebalances between map tasks so that you
end up with Kiski and the tasks actually
finished at about the same time and we
can also push down predicate filters and
column filters into bigquery so that way
you reduce the amount of data that's
actually write out and finally the last
major improvement there is you look at
SPARC in particular so I put it up on
the slide you know in the old connector
you kind of have to use the Map Reduce
API which is very difficult to work with
but now we integrate with the SPARC data
source API so now it's just sparked
outrage dot bigquery give it a table
name and you have a type data frame
that's you know correct that you can use
in your spark jobs it's also a connector
for MapReduce as well so kind of similar
there's another connector as well for
cloud spanner it is also open source on
github actually all three of them I'm
going to talk about are on github and
this one is still under active
development but kind of the same concept
here we push down filters and it
integrates with these spark data source
API such as spark to read format cloud
spanner and again you have a correctly
typed data frame to work with and
finally I'll run through some quick
improvements in the GCSE connector
there's there's been like a lot of work
in the GCSE connector in the past year
especially around performance so the
first big one is really around
supporting columnar file formats so the
idea is with these columnar file formats
you might have like a footer at the end
of the file and so if you're filtering
data you might be able to
skip the entire file or just read a
small section of it so we really
improved random access patterns in the
GCS connector and that's what really
makes it like up to four times faster
for certain parking workloads and the
other major improvement was around
multi-threaded batch requests so if
you're renaming a large directory or
deleting a large directory that is now
significantly faster and so again just
to kind of reiterate the big thing here
is we're really focused on being good
open-source citizens that are
proprietary connectors these are all
open source on github and the community
can also contribute to them and with
that I'll hand it off to Michaela and
talk about Auto awesomeness all right so
what is auto awesomeness so auto
awesomeness basically means that we
manage your infrastructure for you so
that you can just focus on the insights
and we have a whole host of different
auto awesome features that help you do
this so we have lots of features that
help you manage clusters so for example
one is scheduled deletion so let's say I
have a cluster and I want to say okay if
this cluster is idle for more than ten
minutes
I want data proc to just automatically
you delete it for you so you can set
that up and then we manage your jobs too
so we have the jobs API we have eight
different job types now so that it's
easy to submit jobs through whatever
automation that you're using and then we
also have ways to manage clusters and
jobs together so on the next slide I'm
going to talk about workflow templates
so what is a workflow template what is a
workflow so a workflow template is a way
to specify a graph of jobs that you want
to run so any arbitrary like job
dependencies alongside the configuration
for the cluster that you want those jobs
to run on so when you run a workflow
what happens is data proc will spin up a
cluster on your behalf run the graph of
jobs on that cluster and then tear down
the cluster and even if something goes
wrong in the workflow will clean up the
cluster for you so that you don't have
to worry about it you can do all of this
with a single API call which is really
powerful
so you can actually run a workflow right
directly from the UI and then you can
monitor the progress of this workflow as
well so you can see the jobs and this
workflow this is just a simple like
Terrigen pterosaur tara validate the
Terrigen job is done
the terasort job is running and the tara
validate job is waiting for the terasort
job to finish
so another auto awesome feature that we
have for managing your jobs that's
coming soon is the ability to see all
the logs associated with a particular
job in stackdriver
logging all in one place so you can
select a particular job by job ID and
just a drop-down and then you
automatically see all the driver logs
and all the container logs all in one
place here in stackdriver
and stackdriver is not just used for
logging it's also used for monitoring so
we have full integration with stack
driver monitoring as well so we export
metrics from your cluster just after
every monitoring and that's actually how
our autoscaler makes decisions about how
to scale so to talk to you more about
auto scaling i'm gonna hand it back to
karthik real quick
yes I really see auto-scaling is the
premier auto-awesome feature because
auto-scaling kind of really the story of
clouded the idea that you just pay for
the resources that you use so with auto
scaling jobs are fire and forget and
then auto scaling can scale up and down
clusters to match your workload so we
still want to give you low-level control
into how auto scaling works so
importantly you can set the minimum
cluster size and the maximum cluster
size and you can also control how
aggressive the autoscaler responds to
yarn metrics so just to kind of dig in
data proc runs yarn it's called yet
another resource negotiator and it's
kind of the scheduler for Hadoop and all
Hadoop jobs run on top of yarn so if you
take a MapReduce job for example a
MapReduce job gets split into a set of
map tasks and a set of reduced tasks
which is an including yarn to be
scheduled on the cluster if there's a
lot of work pending in the queue then we
should scale the cluster up but if
there's a lot of free space left in the
cluster that we shouldn't scale it down
because we have too much capacity so we
allow you to choose how to respond to
these yarn metrics and how aggressively
so for example something neat you can do
is you have very high priority jobs you
can actually set it so the cluster just
scales up when you submit a lot of jobs
but only scales down when the cluster is
idle to avoid interrupting any jobs that
are in progress so last year we launched
auto scaling to alpha this year we're
launching it to beta and there have been
a whole slew of improvements and I'll go
through a few here so first we've
enhanced the fine-grained controls that
you have over auto scaling so for
example now you can update auto scaling
policies at any time you can also stop
auto scaling on clusters this is
especially important for long-running
clusters where you might need to tune
the autoscaler over time we've also
focused a lot on usability so you might
have noticed in the cluster page that
you now have a dashboard of yarn and
HDFS metrics and this really helps
understand why the autoscaler is scaling
up or down you know based on the
utilization in your cluster and we've
also put the auto scaling decision
history and stackdriver logging as well
and finally we focused on jobs to Bill
the ability to scale up and down
MapReduce and spark jobs without having
them fail and we'll touch on that more a
little bit later so I'm just giving you
a little teaser so switch gears here and
talk about preemptable VM so preemptable
VMS are kind of a really neat concept in
google cloud there are instances that
are up to 80 percent cheaper but can be
preempted which really means that
they're kind of taken away they're shut
down at any time if GC needs to sell
that capacity elsewhere so a lot of
workloads are ok with nodes joining and
leaving and that means that this like
80% cheaper VMs can actually make it way
more cost-effective so you think that
the Hadoop ecosystem is built around
this idea of nodes coming and leaving so
you add a bunch of preemptable VMs to
your cluster but then your jobs start
actually failing so Mikael will talk a
little bit more about why this is
alright so you added a whole bunch of
preemptable games to your cluster and
your job started feeling so what's going
on so let's do a brief refresher on like
the anatomy of a MapReduce job to kind
of understand what's happening here
so in MapReduce you got your mappers and
you got your reducers so you have your
map tasks running on those nodes and
then your reduced tasks need to fetch
data from your mappers so they fetch the
output of the map tasks from those nodes
and so your job is going along it's like
almost done but then one of your mappers
gets preempted and as a result of this
all those reducers that were fetching
data from that mapper those reduced
tasks also fail so now not only do you
have to rerun this map task you also
have to rerun all those reduced tasks
that were fetching data from that mapper
so that's kind of unfortunate so we've
actually launched a feature to alpha
that helps mitigate this issue so can
you switch over to the demo stream all
right
this feature is called enhanced
flexibility mode and we have it for both
MapReduce and spark so can you start
that video so first we're gonna show you
an example of what happens when you
don't have enhanced flexibility mode
enabled so here I'm submitting a job to
a cluster and this is just like a tiny
like 10 gigabyte shuffle and this
cluster does not have enhanced
flexibility mode enabled so what we're
gonna do is once this job gets going I'm
going to remove the preemptable workers
from this cluster and we're gonna see
what happens to the job progress and
it's not good so just waiting for this
to get started and then after this we'll
show you what happens when enhanced
flexibility mode is enabled which is
very exciting
alright so we're gonna switch over to
the cluster tab here or editing this
cluster it used to have five preemptable
workers and we're reducing that to zero
so now we're scaling this cluster down
getting rid of those instances and let's
monitor our job progress to see what
happens I know that's kind of hard to
see but looks like we're like 71%
we're like chugging along if we go back
over to the cluster tab and look at
those instances we see those VMs are now
getting removed all right so let's check
back in on the job and alright it went
down from 75% to 21% so all that
progress was lost you have to rerun
those tasks which is pretty unfortunate
so Karthik can you switch to the next
video so now we're gonna talk about what
happens this is the exact same setup but
this cluster has enhanced flexibility
mode enabled so same setup like five
preemptable is like two normal workers
submitting the same job like a 10
gigabyte shuffle yep and then so with
enhanced flexibility mode we actually
write the output of those map tasks to a
distributed file system so that
it's check pointed and you don't lose
that progress so once a map task has
finished it'll never have to be rerun
again for any reason so we'll watch the
job progress for this one and see what
happens so wait for the job to get going
and then scaled on the cluster again and
now it's important to point out that in
flight map tasks will still be killed so
you will still see some progress lost
but all the map tasks that are already
done that progress is saved all right so
we're switching over to the cluster tab
we're going to edit the configuration to
only have zero preemptable workers and
then again we'll watch what happens with
that job alright it looks like we're it
I can barely read that 58% and we can go
see those beams yep alright the PM's are
going away now so we can check back in
on our job alright so this time the
progress went from 58 percent to 45
percent so that's like way less dramatic
than what it was before and the other
one where it went from like 75 to 21 or
something like that and then also keep
in mind this is like a tiny 10 gigabyte
job here so for larger jobs the like
percentage of the total job of progress
that is lost is a lot smaller yeah so
with this feature this is also it works
well with scaling so I guess if you
wanted to see no job progress loss at
all you can actually use graceful
decommissioning so with graceful
decommissioning we wait for the
containers to finish on the nodes before
we remove the nodes and usually so with
enhanced flexibility mode this is a
little bit different than how yarn
graceful decommissioning normally works
so with enhanced flexibility mode as
soon as those containers are done so as
soon as those
tasks are done on those nodes we can
remove the nodes right away even if the
application isn't done yet so this is
different than how yarn graceful
decommission normally works normally
those nodes have to sit around for the
entire duration of the application
because they're still serving shuffle
data but now they're not now that
shuffle data is in a distributed file
system so we can remove those nodes
sooner and so now scaling can be more
responsive I'll hand it over to Chris I
think we can switch back to the
questions slide could we switch back to
can you advance the slide so yeah that's
the end of the session everybody we did
try to save some time for Q&A so there's
probably a lot of questions about these
features and we're happy to speak with
those so just because this so if you
want to just anyone that wants to come
to the mic happy to answer questions
excuse me oh did you have a chance to
benchmark the performance impact of
spilling all of the shuffle data to disk
or I mean - yes yes so we did some
benchmarking so we benchmarked against
HDFS and GCS as well so far like small
to mid-size shuffles it actually looked
all right for bigger shuffles that's
something that we're actually working on
actively like this quarter to improve it
so this is kind of like an alpha launch
and we wanted to get it out there for
use to like start experimenting with
so we're kind of like actively seeking
feedback for I guess people who are
using this feature main character these
APIs Kevin kids mostly the horizontal
it's not a vertical yes that's correct
it's only horizontal scaling it's
something we've thought about but at the
moment no I mean if if you want to talk
about your use case I'd definitely be
like come and find me afterwards okay
yeah I'm curious why you're interested
in it this little skater is bigger cool
is that
do you basically have your own like
first part for example do you have your
own Fork of sparked to be able to do
such a thing so for the enhanced
flexibility part sort of yes and and
this is stuff that we plan to open
source actually we as we said earlier we
were trying to be good open-source
citizens here
so Ben actually is a person that did
spark and hence flexibility and Makayla
didn't MapReduce and does that rely on
yarn I guess I just spark already
scheduled is its executives on yarn sex
bark on yarn is already in the spark
project I'm thinking that in the future
that will be pretty awesome if we can
run take advantage of this feature for
example in the queue radius world and
have the shuffle files being stored in
GCS I guess is where I'm going with that
we're you think say well in what were
kubernetes human Eddie's yes so yeah
exactly as well this is awesome
yes oh yeah definitely all stuff were
thinking about I so my question is more
on like let's say there's an optional
component that I installed and you
that you have support for playing 1.6
but right now if link is at 1.8 and
there's some features I want how easy is
it to upgrade it is there a way to apply
a patch or we have to set up our own
plink cluster across the cluster
ourselves or is there a way of easily
upgrading it so if you're purely looking
for like a particular patch like a bug
fix it's pretty easy like reach out to
data proxied back or I can you know talk
to you afterwards we do do patches if
you're talking about version upgrades of
link that we do as well I mean we do try
to stay pretty up-to-date especially in
SPARC but as people were like requests
we do our best to keep up with the
community and we really respond as much
as we can to customers that are pushing
for the latest and greatest but you do
have full control of the virtual
machines so if you wanted to upgrade
that whatever is on the operating system
you do have root access to it and can do
what you want right you know second
question is that spark has a lot of its
own optimizations such as adaptive
solution adaptive execution mode and
cost based optimization in your fork are
you kind of letting spark do all its
work that it does or are you overtaking
some of the things that sparked us to
have this enhanced flexibility or
checkpointing or those kind of things
sorry can you say one more time are we
you overwrite sparks native features to
have your own schedule yeah all of that
is the same yeah okay right now is
purely around shuffle so that that's so
like cache data for example is not yet
enhanced leaf flexible
my questions more around like let's say
they're skewing your data and then spark
kind of recognizes that and dynamically
partitions it so you're not touching any
of that no okay so go yeah if you turn
on like cost based optimization in like
2.3 then yeah should all still work okay
cool thank you yeah and then when there
are kind of overlaps with this like for
instance I had Mikaela brought up
graceful decommissioning that is
something that we're trying to change in
the open-source park and push upstream
so when we do hit the over
we are trying to work with the community
on it my question is I wanted to ask you
about graceful decommissioning is it not
fulfilling the proposed that you have
presented already is it when you
configure graceful decommissioning it's
not like waiting until the map job is
done before it does so right now so if
you have enhanced flexibility mode
enabled so we actually made some changes
to graceful decommissioning so that it
works better with enhanced flexibility
mode so it does it waits for those map
tasks to be done before decommissioning
those nodes so when I was showing in the
demo I actually didn't use graceful
decommissioning and that's why we saw
some progress lost even with enhanced
flexibility mode on because we didn't
wait for those in-flight containers to
finish but with graceful decommissioning
we wait for the containers to finish but
we don't wait for the entire application
to finish because now we don't need to
because the shuffle data is like
preserves the nodes don't have to serve
it did that answer the question I just
wanted to say I think just below the
nationalisation action where you can
quickly choose the HBase or or Ranger
whatever you like oh yeah I totally
agree so there's this yeah this feedback
yeah thank you hopefully by the next
next that will be their first question
any plan to expand
you know the preview image list right
now like you know if you look at these
options you know it's like you know
comparing to you you know general you
know excursion execution machine you
have like a long list of options but if
you go or data plug it's maybe like five
six and the different options of
pre-built image this I think there's
more than five or six but like we do try
to address this with custom images where
you do have the capability to come in
put whatever you would like on the image
oftentimes enterprises with strict
security controls who put their own
security constraints on it or you might
have some additional versions that you
want to upgrade independently you have
the ability to do that and then you can
create a custom image and then come back
and use that image so we do give you the
flexibility to do what you need to do
with the image so like you will result
in you know in your customizations they
like so we just added Ubuntu because we
guys just based on customer demand so if
you do have use cases for that I'd love
to talk to you about it and see if it
makes sense to do additional images
because that's where you Boone who came
from as just customers were asking for
it okay I mean there's well a little bit
more background when to is also very
straightforward because the same package
is between Debian and Ubuntu so that's
another reason that Santos is like
potentially more difficult to ok we are
looking for support next question is
what's the difference between you know
the templates and there is there's
actually before I'll let them talk more
but there actually is an integration
point between them so cloud composer
does have a workflow templates operator
so you can drop into a composer this
operator and that will do all of your
data proc jobs in cluster all if one
black box entity within composer so
there is an integration point and that's
how customers typically work together
with them I don't know if you want to
add more to that yeah I mean I was
basically just gonna say this
thing like a workflow a datapack
workflow can be like one node in a
composer like a bigger composer
orchestration yeah so like I mean
composer is integrated with like all
sorts of different things in GCP
workflow templates are kind of are like
data proc native workflows so you could
do the same thing and composer but it's
kind of annoying and composer to have to
be like okay let me create a cluster and
then submit these jobs and then tear
down the cluster like all these nodes in
the graph where logically it's just like
one operation so like data practice this
part of my overall pipeline if you like
you know say like I don't want to have
anyway yeah so I mean there's there's a
workflow operator like a datapack
workflow operator in airflow so you can
use your same workflow templates from
data proc in a composer okay one of the
things to consider is that data proc
workflows are really just a community
way of saying I want to run these jobs
in this cluster but there's no actual
native scheduling well if you want to
say like run this job twice a day or
like when data arrives in GCS you have
overlap the function you know between
templates and yep not the only if like
you know these two are total
exchangeable and you know compatible
yeah it just kind of down to our general
theory about like we try to expose a lot
of knobs and so you want to turn the
more detailed knobs you can do that
directly in composer you want to
abstract that all away and treat it this
one black box
you know workflow template box even do
that and that way you might even have
define in what organization you're in
like there might be something that does
the data proc workflow templates and
then they can hand off that entire black
box to the person doing you know cloud
compose their airflow workflow so it's
just sort of where do you want to turn
this knob different I definitely see
them
yeah so right now this is just the reed
connector so there's not a similar right
connector yet the right connector is
like whenever you know it's a process
right so yes you ready to GCS and then
GC has loads into bigquery but sometimes
the load phase but your character
doesn't retry you know like we have to
see for you to try because it's part of
your connector right so yeah there's a
lot of the libraries have low-level
retries but yeah that's something to
look into like again our connectors on
github so if you file an issue there
we'll also take a look so if graceful
different commissioning well wait until
the completion of the task regardless
right so in the original version when
you saw that 50% drop if you had
graceful decommissioning yeah I've seen
any drop at all so we wouldn't have but
it's kind of a pain because the nodes
wouldn't be removed from the cluster
until the application is completely done
so I guess another a big benefit of the
enhanced flexibility mode is you can
remove nodes from your cluster you're
faster so you're not paying for them
when all they're doing is like serving
shuffle data and it's also like okay
sorry I was going I was considering like
if that's the main benefit right this
new feature in the sense
you can tear down faster do we do you
have any kind of numbers on what the
distribution what the benefit is of like
a job - its shuffle time and - the cost
um so I don't have exact numbers but I
guess again for like small or medium
sized shuffles like the times of the
jobs are like comparable I guess and
then for larger shuffles sometimes
especially if you're using HDFS there
can be some like bottlenecking
issues with the name node and you can
tune the name node to avoid those if you
use GCS you don't see those issues as
much but this is why we decided to make
this feature a public alpha versus a EAP
or a private alpha ik so we want as many
people testing it as possible so we can
start to do these benchmarks and figure
out best practices and that way when we
do hit you know ei which is hey we
really trust this that's going to become
coupled with and here's the type of cost
savings you can expect or here's the
kind of trade-offs you can expect with
these different settings and so we do we
do plan to get more crisp on a lot of
that stuff or right now it's just about
getting it out there getting folks using
it and it's starting to test out a lot
of this stuff and then again I mean
another like one of the huge like
reasons we did this feature is to help
you with cost savings so I guess like if
you want to use a lot of critical VMs so
I guess in the demo I showed me like
purposely removing the preemptable VMS
but you don't know when the preemptable
VMS are going to go away so like when
the preemptable VMS get preempted like
there's no graceful decommissioning
there I guess so I guess that's why I
demoed what I did oh yes it does not
know yeah so it's to help with that that
makes sense yeah like one quick one
afterwards yes basically for the auto
scaling I noticed it's in beta do you
guys have an idea or a timeline for when
it would be in GA not a firm timeline
but the idea is in like the next quarter
- yeah okay thanks
[Applause]
[Music]